اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء اعلانات
السلطات البولنديه مقتل شخصين جر السقوط
صاروخان قالت انه روسي الصنع داخل الاراضي
الفرديه امس وقالت وزاره الخارجيه
البولنديه
برجيودو في مقاطعه لوبسكي قرب الحدود
الاوكرانيه واضفت انه تم استدعاء السفير
الروسي في بولندا حدث
نقلت رويترز عن الرئيس البولندي
ليس لديها اي دليل ملموس حول من اطلق
الصاروخ الذي سقط على اراضيها لكن الصاروخ
على الارجح صناعه روسيه على حديقه
اعلنت السلطات البولنديه التاهب العسكريه
ودعتني اجتماع عاجل لمجلس الامن القومي
اليوم وقالت الحكومه البولنديه انها قررت
زياده الاستعداد القتاليه لوحدات النخبه
في القوات المسلحه البولنديه مع التركيز
بشكل خاص على مراقبه المجال الجوي
في المقابل نفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
علاقتها بالمساله واتهمت الوزاره وسائل
الاعلام البولنديه بالقيام باستفزازات
المتعمده لتصعيد الموقف اضفت ان مصر لم
توجه اي اسلحه روسيه لضرب اهداف قرب
الحدود البولنديه الاخرانيه
وعقد الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اجتماعا
طارئا صباح اليوم مع زعماء الدول الحليفه
لوشنطن المشاركين في قمه العشرين
باندونيسيا لبحث التطورات في بولندا
وعقبال الاجتماع قال بيضا ان الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في النيتو يتحرون عن
الانفجار الذي ادى لمقتل شخصين في بولندا
لكن المعلومات الاوليه تشير الى انه ربما
لم يكن ناجما عن صاروخ اطلق من روسيا وفق
قوله وقال ايضا ان الولايات المتحده و دول
حلف الناتو ستحقق في الواقعه بشكل كامل
قبل التصرف
في سياق المتصله وكاله الصوفيه عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان نتائج اوليه ترجحوا ان
الصاروخ الذي سقط ببولندا اطلقته قوه
اوكرانيه لاعتراض صاروخ روسي من جهته قال
المتحدث
رايدر ان وزاره الدفاع تاخذ سلامه قواتها
في بولندا وغيرها على محمل الجد وانهم
واثقون من اجراءات الحمايه لكنهم لم
يستبقوا الامور
قال منسقوا السياسه الخارجيه والامن في
الاتحاد الاوروبيه لانه يبحث عقد اجتماعا
تنسيقيه لقاده الاتحاد الاوروبيه على
هامشي قمه العشرين في بالي اندونيسيا من
جهتها قالت المتحدثه باسم حلف الناتو
من العامله
اجتماع طارق اليوم الاربعاء
لبحث في حادث سقوط صاروخان في بولندا
قتل ثلاثه مستوطنين واصيب اثنان في هجوم
منه شاب فلسطيني في محيط المستوطنه بالضفه
الغربيه كما استشهد منفذ الهجوم برصاص
جندي اسرائيلي واكد وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ان اجهزه الامنيه ماضيه في
محاربه ما وصفه بالارهاب في حين شنت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حملته ده من واعتقال
في الضفه الغربيه
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه وقال
امام تجمع لانصاره بمقر اقامته في فلوريدا
انه ترشح لا يجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
تعبير
على سعيد المتصل الي افادت وكاله السوشيت
بريسبيت اتجاه الجمهوريين لتحقيق اغلبيه
بسيطه في مجلس النواب الامريكي بعد
تحقيقهم 217 مقعدا مقابله 129
للديمقراطيين مع ترقب اكتمال نتائج
الانتخابات في ولايه كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]